let me segue it because I did write a
book and what it is is my father is 70
and my mother is God only knows where
she is she may not be with us anymore
but what I wanted to do before they died
was just one more disgraceful moment
yeah like a head hung low moment where I
could share all these like horrific
stories like my father I was smoking
cigarettes 13 years old smoking
cigarettes the front seat of his car he
let me smoke cigarettes and he goes you
know what's good about you you never
smoke them down to the filter
and I threw him out the window and he
goes you know and that's like
picture like other kids talking about
what kids like what their [__]
self-esteem comes from and then they get
to you because I'm used to I didn't I do
that's really good yeah yeah I would go
you have to let me smoke so they were
getting divorced and my father's like
well he's just smoking a pack